drew barrymore she reunited with her
ex-husband tom green
for the first time in nearly 20 years
today on the drew barrymore show
when you say like 20 years it's
sometimes it's the blink of an
eye and sometimes you're like oh my god
we've lived so much in these last 20
years
i was so happy when you invited me on
the show it's been it's been too long
why take 20 years for you guys to talk
for tom and i were like wow there's been
a lot of growth and life lived on both
sides
of our universes i don't think there was
any bad or negativity i just think it
was an unsustainable rocket ship of a
ride
the whirlwind romance started in 2000
when drew meant tom on the set of
charlie's angels
they eloped a year later we are married
we got married in cleveland we did
a week ago but the marriage lasted just
five months
tom filed for divorce citing
irreconcilable differences
e.t saw their connection firsthand as
drew helped tom through his battle with
testicular cancer
disney looks sexy yeah see there's a red
carpet right there sir yeah that's not
that's this is perfect
yeah now this is the type of award show
i want to go to oh the live v doesn't
roll on the carpet
you could see the seriousness behind
that it was almost like you were like
we're joking but that was such a serious
moment
as much as i had lived a very public
life
i was not a bring the cameras in and you
know
peel the layers back he was doing
reality television before there was
reality television
i pretended and tried to be comfortable
in it but i was
in shock and odd